here we describe the general process of
splicing and demonstrate how an open
reading frame is maintained within the
mature messenger RNA or mRNA in
eukaryotes mRNA is transcribed from the
5 prime to 3 prime direction using one
strand of DNA as template as the RNA is
generated it is processed in order to
give rise to a mature message one key
step of RNA processing is splicing we
can use english letters words and
sentences to illustrate the key concepts
of splicing let us imagine that the
following precursor message has been
generated let us also pretend that each
letter of this transcript is a
nucleotide as written this message does
not make much sense but if we highlight
the exons using red letters we can
identify a short sentence when we read
just those letters conveniently for this
illustration all the exons are short but
do keep in mind that exons and introns
are of variable lengths in real life the
minimal size for an intron is about 40
nucleotides since the process message is
a complete English sentence the first
six letters of the precursor message
highlighted in blue before the definite
article the corresponds to the five
prime untranslated region or five prime
UTR the blue letters after the red
letters end correspond to the three
prime UTR the untranslated regions often
contain information that helps regulate
translation the black letters between
the exons correspond to introns an
intron begins with a five prime splice
donor site and ends with a three prime
splice acceptor site remember that the
five prime splice donor site of the
intron usually has the sequence GT while
the three prime
place acceptor site has the sequence AG
when we remove all the introns and begin
reading at the first word the message
tells us that the fat old cat ate the
big rat the is the beginning of our
process message and represents the start
codon of the open reading frame when you
read this message your brain converts
the message into a mental image
similarly the translational machinery
reads the processed transcript and
converts it into a protein because an
exon could end in the middle of a word
we use the term phase to describe the
number of letters between the last
complete word or codon and the five
prime splice donor site if the last base
of the codon coincides with the end of
an exon then we would consider the five
prime splice donor site for that exon to
be in phase zero in this example the
word fat in our message is complete
before the splice donor site hence we
would consider this splice donor site to
be in phase zero if the splice site cuts
off the codon in an exon after one base
we would consider the five prime splice
donor site for that exon to be in phase
one in this example the word cat is
split between two exons the letter C is
in exon two and the letters A and T are
in exon 3 if the splice site cuts off
the codon in an exon after two bases we
would consider the five prime splice
donor site for that exon to be in Phase
two in this example the word eight is
split between two exons the letters A
and T are in exon 3 and the letter E is
in exon for note that the phase of the 5
prime donor site must be compatible with
the phase of the 3 prime acceptor site
the sum of the donor and acceptor phases
must either be 0 no additional codon or
3 an additional codon do remember to
analyze splice junctions carefully
examine the splice junction between
exons four and five there are two ways
to form the words big rat
however only the second option utilizes
the canonical 5 prime splice donor and
the 3 prime splice acceptor sites in
intron 4